The 1912 gift of 3,020 flowering cherry trees from the city of Tokyo to Washington...
...was a milestone in the development of relations between the United States and Japan.
It grew into an act of diplomacy and goodwill...
...that would put a lasting mark on the Washington landscape and community.
The idea of planting cherry trees in the city's new Potomac Park...
...had been proposed about 25 years earlier...
...by Washington author, journalist, and world traveler Eliza Ruhamah Scidmore,...
...who became enamored with cherry blossoms during trips to Japan that began in 1885.
The dream finally took root in 1909,...
...when first lady Helen "Nellie" Taft, prodded by a note from Scidmore,...
...took up the project as part of her own plans for developing Potomac Park.
Mrs. Taft replied to Scidmore on April 7, 1909.
"I have taken the matter up and am promised the trees,...
...but I thought perhaps it would be best to make an avenue of them,...
...extending down to the turn in the road."
With support from Tokyo's Mayor Yukio Ozaki,...
...two thousand trees were shipped to Washington and arrived in early 1910.
Unfortunately, most had to be burned because of infestation.
The Japanese government resolved to send a fresh,...
...even larger shipment of trees that would be free of diseases and pests.
A committee of experts worked closely with Seisaku Funatsu,...
...a cherry tree grower at Tokyo's Arakawa River embankment,...
...to select and raise trees for the second gift.
Funatsu selected twelve varieties of trees,...
...which were grafted to specially selected rootstock and nurtured for a year...
...at the Imperial Horticultural Station of Okitsu before being shipped to Washington.